hey here once again it's 3 p.m. it's
Monday isn't it yeah it's the same it's
Omega man day with the global panting
we're just worried about getting up and
getting our iced tea and yeah getting so
much every single time every single all
right so I've been really wanting to
talk about this for a long time but I
wanted to be able to finish series
because like I said I had been like
really stoked about watching season
three of dark but because it had been
such a long time since I had seen season
1 and 2 and since the show is if you've
seen it like mind-bogglingly complex so
I said well I'm just gonna watch all
three seasons like over the course of a
week or week and a half so I'm all
caught up on everything so I'm not
completely lost because I figured that
would be so I finally finished watching
it yesterday and I have to say I mean ok
from a writing standpoint this is one of
the most genius things that I have that
has ever been written I mean just in awe
of like the complexity of it and how you
know it's it's hard to do like a sci-fi
thing with time travel and a lot of
stuff has been done with time travel but
the way that they did it in this show
they almost kind of they grounded it in
this sort of a reality type of thing but
this is one of the only things that I've
seen maybe twelve Monkeys as well but
this is one of the only sci-fi series
that I've seen where time travel
actually kind of makes sense like in a
real world sort of way if that makes any
sense because they obviously did put a
lot of thought into what would happen
like what particular consequences would
happen from certain time you know you
know going through time displacements
and things like that so but I will say
that if you're not cuz Tom didn't really
watch it yeah I couldn't really get into
it did have some like to see some of the
episodes it had really cool like scenes
and [ __ ] happens
you know in these different time zones
one of them's kind of post-apocalyptic
it was cool it's kind of like kind of
like some it's kind of like stranger
things because some of it takes place in
the 80s some of it place take takes
place in the future so it's kind of like
walking dead but mysterious [ __ ] happens
visual looks real good acting is really
good it's all in German dialogue so you
gotta read subtitles yeah they have an
English dub on Netflix that I would not
recommend I don't usually like dubbing
anyway I think it's a high quality
series it's just not really for me well
it's one that you definitely have to you
have to pay attention to there every
single thing you have to watch each
because every single thing means
something there's not really action
driven it's it's story driven I guess
and a bunch of weird [ __ ] happens and it
all intertwines across all these
different time periods so she has a hard
time following it that means I can't
follow it I'm like a monkey I followed
it but there was some stuff like later
on because I watched I've only watched
season three one time but I watched
season one and two like two times there
was a lot of stuff that I picked up on
the second time through that didn't I
mean it didn't like get in the way of my
enjoyment like I wasn't totally lost or
anything like that but it just made me
appreciate how much detail like how much
thought went into this because there was
like all these little things in there
that related back to thing that I was
just like oh [ __ ] I just like totally
forgot about that so it was more like
picking up like all these extra things
like as opposed because honestly if
you're paying attention the one thing
that you mainly have to pay attention to
and this is why the Wikipedia page has
like a big huge family tree of all these
the four main families in the town of
vinden where it takes place is that you
have to remember how all the characters
are related to one another and because
it takes place in several different 33
year periods there's you know there's
1986 there's 2019 there's 2050 - there's
1954 there's 1888
I think there's some like back 1921 so
you have to remember to what each
iteration of the characters look like
like at there are different ages and who
their parents are who their grandparents
are like so you have to like remember
all of that like while you're watching
it like for maximum impact which like I
said that's why you know the Wikipedia
page is the dark official page they have
like all these really complicated family
timelines because you have to like
follow all that to know and what the
hell is going on with the time loop it's
not a time travel movie like say Back to
the Future or what's another time travel
movie like this is this is a time travel
movie that's kind of like what's the
twelve Monkeys yeah this is of that type
that's probably the most similar thing
that I mean even though it's not in a
lot of ways it's not like twelve Monkeys
but it does have a similar yeah it's not
like Doctor Who where they're jumping
around through no no it's not like that
it's it's more like twelve Monkeys well
it's based in actual theoretical physics
you know so the stuff like I don't know
if it's possible or not I mean
theoretically possible for [ __ ] to
happen the way that [ __ ] happens in this
one of the main things that is kind of
like a brain breaking sort of thing that
takes place a lot in this show is what's
called the bootstrap paradox where
something I don't know if I can explain
it all that well but it's it's basically
where something their cause and effect
become like dis disengaged from one
another so there can be a thing that
exists and for example like if a dude
you know invented a time machine and
this it's like a book about time travel
the dude invented a time machine and
then went back in time to give the plans
to the time machine to his younger self
so that he builds the time machine and
you cause like this infinite loop so you
can kind of argue that like no one that
it didn't have a creation or it didn't
have an origin point because it just
keeps going like circling back around so
if that is that is kind of like the main
point of this show because you know the
whole point is that there are you know
there's one world you think it's just
one so like I said if this is gonna be a
lot of spoilers so if you haven't like
gone to see
three or you don't like know anything
about what happened in season three
because it was kind of like a big thing
like it went off in a crazy other
direction um then I'm gonna spoil it so
you know if you don't want to know what
happens then you might want to like duck
out now but what you think is happening
through the whole like mostly second
season the first season there is time
travel in it but it's mostly set up like
almost like a crime procedural like with
all these little kids going missing and
like kids turning up dead in this town
and everything and you're not really
sure why but then slowly you you find
out like about all the time-travel
shenanigans that are going on now in the
second one they pretty much explained
that all of these things that are
happening are basically you don't know
how many times that all of these actions
have have looped through but apparently
there are two essential groups one of
whom led by Adam who was grown up yonas
and he's all like deformed and stuff and
he heads sick Mundus you know the the
group that like the time-traveling group
his kind of thing is he wants to cause
the apocalypse so he can kill the origin
now he thinks that the origin is the
child of Jonas from the world that we
know in season one and two and if you
didn't know season three like I said
it's it's you know it's complicated
enough that the show had like people
being their you know their daughters or
their moms and like you know everyone's
like related to like a kid goes back in
time and like father's a kid and they
exist in the same time period and all
this other stuff so they had all that
complicated [ __ ] going on but then when
season three started they were basically
like hey hold my heifer vison because
now there's alternate realities also so
what you don't know is that you thought
in the first time it was just this one
loop but actually it's - there are two
worlds and they are connected and
there's like a switch point so they use
like this infinite loop type of thing
the other world vinden be is what they
usually call it like on the Wikipedia
page and stuff is kind of similar to
vinden a like in the sense that most of
the characters are still there but yonas
does not exist because Mikkel
never went
back in time and became his father in
that particular world so everything's
like a little bit different I was
listening to like a physicist talked
about you know time space time and and
everything and he it was somebody asking
a question about those loops could you
go back in time and give yourself you
know a book and where I think he said
that that's that that that only seems
strange to us from a certain point yeah
that the universe wouldn't give a [ __ ]
the universe wouldn't give a [ __ ] where
that came from
it would do it allow it well that is
nothing to prevent that yeah that's kind
of what's happening with this show
because this happens with multiple
things I mean the book by HG tan house
which is called a journey through time
they never show him because the
character is in there but they never
show him writing that book and he only
knows how to build the time machine
because Claudia came from the future the
post-apocalyptic future and came all the
way back with the plans where did she
get the plans we don't really know
there's another that same guy and I
forgot his name he said you could go
back in time and kill yourself too and
kill you that the universe wouldn't
notice your mass would be there in that
new time and space it didn't have to
have an origin because it's there now
yeah late you came out of nowhere what
they did with this it doesn't have to be
linear yeah and that's kind of like what
the first two seasons of this show were
kind of like setting up you know these
this infinite loop
where it was possible for someone like
for example in the first season you find
out that you know this kid goes missing
Erik open door was the first one that
goes missing that's kind of the first
main you know thing of the series and
then so like all the other high school
students go down to you know the wind
and caves the venden caves where to get
the kids drug stash because he was kind
of like the school drug dealer so they
were like hey we know where he keeps his
drugs so let's go down there that
results in Mikkel who was the younger
younger brother of Magnus and Marta and
that leads to him disappearing into the
caves going back to 1986 and fathering
Jonas who was in high school in 2019
even
No 2019 Jonas and Mikkel were in the
same reality at the same time you know
what I mean
but Mikkel had to travel back in time to
be his father
so when yonus finds out about the time
travel and finds out about the caves and
that there's like there's you know we're
essentially a wormhole like in the caves
he decides he's going to go back to 1986
and bring Mikkel back because you know
his parents Catarina and Ulrich are very
upset as they would be but then an older
version of himself which is called
stranger Jonas comes and tells him hey
you can't take Mikkel back to his own
time because then you will not exist
because he is your father so he has to
stay back here in night 86 and be raised
and become your dad yeah I don't know if
that would really happen though yeah but
they're they're just saying yeah well it
ends up like you know whether it would
really happen or not like I said and I'm
gonna spoil season 3 but once they go
into you know an alternate world and
there are two loops these two loops keep
repeating themselves over and over like
because some of the characters like Adam
and Claudia they they know that this has
happened like a whole bunch of times so
they're trying to you know essentially
break the loop but like in different
ways well Eva who is March a grown up
like in the other world because she's
like the vinden be you know counterpart
of Adam in vinden a she actually wants
to keep the loop going forever
because if she keeps the loop going
forever than her son the unknown will
live forever
whereas Adam is trying to bring about
the apocalypse in both worlds like you
know wiping everyone off the face of the
earth because he thinks he needs that
power to destroy marchis childs the
unknown who what he thinks will break
the link between so he's trying to like
end everything she's trying to keep it
all going so that so there are two like
opposing forces and what you know in the
first two seasons basically it's these
two and they and they're kind of like
soldiers or like the people that they're
manipulating either by sending other
people back into peace like future
versions of themselves like hey you need
to do this that and the other thing just
to get everything in
line four the way things are supposed to
happen depending on what they're you
know what their goal is
yeah but then when season three like
starts to come to a close because Adam
actually does succeed in killing at
least one version of Marta because he
causes the apocalypse in both the loop
worlds and it kills her and that he
expects that that's going to wipe him
from existence but it doesn't and he's
like confused about that because he's
like well I thought I was bringing both
worlds to an end I was breaking the knot
and then Claudia comes to him and
Claudia who was the woman that ran the
nuclear power plant in 1986 and then
like subsequently went on and like she
kept going back in time and like leaping
around what she did evidently was that
she kept going through the cycle again
and again and changing it like a tiny
bit each time so eventually she could
get like out of it and like figure out
was going on and what she figured out
was that even though you think for the
whole show that there's just these two
worlds that are like knotted and they
can't and all the characters in them
can't um you know break out of them like
that no matter what they do it will
always like the outcome will always be
the same so they're like trapped in like
a deterministic universe they're asking
what this is about is it about a
television series called dark yeah
alright it's about time trap it's on
Netflix on Netflix and it's like yeah
it's a it German if you haven't seen it
it's like what I'm talking about it's
gonna sound like the rantings of a crazy
person yeah but uh I think like I said
if you go to the [ __ ] deaf Lacombe
like it's kind of like thirty 12 monkeys
on steroids yeah big time I mean this is
like like I said it's it's hard to
follow just because it's theoretical
physics and that's kind of hard for
everybody to follow but I didn't find it
all that difficult as long as you paid
attention to like how everyone was
related to one another I think that was
kind of the main thing but yeah so you
find out that in season 3 the reason why
Adam wasn't destroyed by killing what he
thought was the origin was that the baby
wasn't the origin I mean the whole
reason he thought it was the origin was
because it was the child of Jonas from
vinden a
Marta from vinden be so he thought well
those two
them getting together paradoxically were
like the parents of everybody else in
the loop because of all the time-travel
shenanigans going on so he thought by
destroying that he was going to destroy
both worlds at the same time so he
didn't die but then Claudia comes out
and she says well actually there's a
third world the origin world which is
funny because this is one of those cool
things and this is what I'm saying like
why this was like written so well is
because through the whole show from the
very beginning of the show one of the
main symbols was the triquetra that you
know that that thing that looked like
that like a diamond like three different
things and everything was done in threes
everything was in 33 year cycles because
that's when all the planets lined up and
all this other stuff and when everybody
jumped through time you did it like in
33 year and that's how long all the
cycles were so I'm surprised that well I
didn't know I don't know I don't know if
anybody predicted it or not like before
season 3 came out but they've but you
know them saying that there's actually a
third world that was outside and the two
worlds that were caught in the loop the
ones that we watched in the first and
second season they were actually
offshoots of an Origin world and were
not even really supposed to exist
whether they were completely
deterministic and whether the people
inside of them could change anything
that seemed kind of unclear because it
seemed like whatever they did it always
ended up with the same outcome like they
both who got blown up in an apocalypse
both the worlds did and it seemed like
no matter what they did that was what
was going to happen like it was
inevitable but it did come to pass that
what the origin actually was was the
invention of time travel itself in the
origin world which was done by HG tan
house and the reason that he ended up
developing the time machine was that his
son and his daughter-in-law and his baby
granddaughter were killed in a car
accident in the 70s and he took the next
like however many years it was I think
it was from 1974 to 1986 or whatever and
he took a nice like building a time
machine and he succeeded
however that time machine when he turned
it on it caused a rift and it broke this
world into two like it split so it made
like these two bubble worlds essentially
that were knotted together and so there
were all these so there were all these
like people within them I mean the whole
point of like these two like looping
things like I said it was deterministic
and it was just like all this misery
like it was just looping misery on
misery and no one could do anything to
change it like all these children dying
and like all these people like it all
these terrible things happening and no
one could stop it even though that was
kind of the you know the the main point
of like all the characters show that's
once they figure it out like the
time-travel thing they were you know
they've kept trying to stop it and they
kept failing but the reason why they
kept failing was because those two
worlds weren't supposed to exist at all
like they were almost kind of like I
don't want to say they were like dream
worlds but they were just like these
these worlds that came about just
because he [ __ ] up the this time
machine because he was trying to bring
his family back from the dead and he
ended up causing these two intertwined
worlds of like endless suffering whose
inhabitants couldn't get out like
couldn't get out of the loop you know
what I mean yeah to answer your
questions you can follow it it's just
you have to watch every goddamn episode
you have to take you have to pay close
attention I would recommend watching it
through and then like giving it a print
it's like don't watch it all through
like in a short time period because your
brain will fry but um you know get but
you do have to like watch it kind of
close together because otherwise you'll
forget everything because there's so
many so many details and everything
feeds back and everything like pretty
much everything means something and it's
you definitely need to watch it through
a few times you know what I mean but if
you keep track of everyone's
relationships to one another that's kind
of the main things you have to remember
like who's parents everybody knows
everything like that and then you'll be
okay and you know who you know went back
in time at what point and all this other
kind of [ __ ] because it is I I will
admit I mean it's very complex it's a
very complex linear story tell and
forget about it
no no no yeah is there's no way and I'm
big into like linear type stories I mean
this real-time yeah
this is a like I said it's a lot to keep
track of like it's a lot to kind of hold
in your brain at once which like I said
I'm glad I watched the first two seasons
like twice because you know I picked up
on a lot more stuff and get you know
because some of the relationships I had
forgotten like especially like some of
them may be minor characters and stuff
and then later I was just like oh you
know what I mean
so it's like a lot richer experience but
yeah if you think that you're not gonna
be able to you know keep track of
everybody and like where everybody's at
like at what year they're pretty good at
like saying you can tell like what year
the [ __ ] is from the clothes from the
actors yeah one thing I have to do you
know speaking of the actors shout-out to
the casting director or directors of
this show because holy [ __ ] they did
because like these characters you see
usually most of the characters you see
like at least three versions of them
like a kid version a middle-aged version
an old person version and I love that
they didn't do like oh let's take the
middle-aged actor and like put old
person makeup on they didn't do that
they found three actors that looked
creepily alike so that so much so that
when you saw like the older version or
the kid version of like a character you
immediately knew who that was like even
before anybody said their name some of
them liked better than others but pretty
much everybody when you saw their
counterpart like in another time period
like the older version of them or the
younger version of them you it wasn't
confusing because you immediately like
knew who it was they did like you know
they would have a character go hey you
know what whatever your name is just in
case you didn't get it but most of the
time you didn't really need that because
all the actors look so much alike
now one thing that they did do I don't
know if they did this for a lot of the
cases but there was a case where the guy
that plays Peter dopler in 2019 his
teenage version that you see in 1987
that is that guy's actual son that
actors actual son so they did actually
use a father-son team they're also the
unknown you know the guy that goes
around with him and his old version his
young
they go around basically assassinating
people that need to get assassinated
Martha's kid that is Martin Martin and
Janice's kid the middle-aged version and
the older version of the unknown were
also father and son but as far as I know
all the other ones were not related and
that like blows my mind because I mean
you know Germany is you know relative to
the United States is a pretty small
country and they don't they probably
don't have this large like an actor pool
like maybe as the US does and the fact
that they could find at least three good
actors one of those being a child actor
that looked that much alike so much so
that you immediately knew what character
that was even though they were 33 years
younger or 33 years older was like
amazing it goes to show that they're not
corrupt here Hollywood would just give
people based on you know what I mean how
much money they wanted to spread around
you know oh we gotta get this kid IO and
we gotta get this piece [ __ ] like that
well the thing about this show is you
can tell that they really really slide I
mean they really tried to make this as I
mean this is easily like a labor of love
so much work went into this so much
detail went into this they even went so
far it's like in the universe of the
show the apocalypse you know where the
nuclear thing like blows up and
everything that happens on June 27th
2020 damn and that's what can hit me
with some em damn flashbulbs thank you
very much oh yeah thank you man
they even went so far as to talkin crazy
whenever I talk crazy Matt gives me
money sorry didn't mean to interrupt
it's just okay good
yes they even went so far as to make the
third season premiere on Netflix on the
same day as the apocalypse was supposed
to happen on the show so like they and
they even did [ __ ] with like doing [ __ ]
33 weeks apart and like all so this is
like this is like some next-level [ __ ]
like the the care that went into this
the writing just everything about it and
like the more I think about it because
I've been like watching some other
videos and like
listen to other people's takes on
everything and like some people that
were pointing out stuff they like little
things like little Easter egg type
things that I had missed and I was just
like this [ __ ] is like it's [ __ ]
genius
it's it is one of the most genius just
the way it was put together it's just
like everything just like ticks together
like a [ __ ] perfectly made watch and
it's just crazy how a story this
sprawling with this many characters
there's many time periods as many
relationships people going back and
forth and time and like they did it on a
computer they well yeah it's like they
must have had I can imagine like what
the [ __ ] spreadsheets like like a dam
gonna be like a board game of three
movies in different parallel universes
and in the progression and how it jumps
across and that's how they wrote the
story yeah and I mean like I said the
main characters were doing in each
little frame in each wit so yeah I mean
there's a gate track of it there's a
character in this Charlotte who doesn't
know who her mom is and then she finds
out that her daughter Elizabeth is also
her mom because of time looking time
travel and like so like I said there's
all this kind of [ __ ] going on and it's
just like it's so [ __ ] crazy that
they kept track of all this stuff now I
was watching a one thing that I thought
was like really really cool this is kind
of apropos of nothing but this was one
thing that I didn't catch when I was
watching it but when I like I saw
somebody else like saying it on a video
or something I was just like oh man
that's so awesome okay so in season 3
and like I said if you haven't seen
season 3 I'm spoiling it so in season 3
Katarina Mickle's mom she goes back in
time trying to find Mikkel she has gone
back and she found all Rick - but that's
like a whole other thing but she goes
back and she tries to she goes back to
1986 once she figures out about the
time-travel and she goes to bring Mikkel
back to 2019 or 2020 at this point and
she goes back there and to bust all Rick
out of the mental asylum where he got
put back in 1954 because he was trying
to find Mikkel - but he overshot it and
went back to 1954 and that's the 98
States and it was just like this whole
thing and then he ended up like getting
arrested because they thought he was
murdered and all these kids and he ended
up in the psychiatric ward so he was
still in there except he was an old man
in 1986 so Katarina goes back to 1986
and finds him in there and it so happens
that her mom back then was worked at the
psychiatric hospital so she tries to get
the key from her mom they get in this
big [ __ ] struggle and her mom and sup
bash in her brains in and killing her
and then throwing her in the [ __ ]
Lake
now I didn't think of this at the time
but two things like later on uh what
kind of went back to well there was
something that happened like before that
that you know this referred back to one
was the st. Christopher medal that yonas
and Marta found in the sand like on the
lake that was that was that belonged to
Katerina's mom and it had come off
during the fight in 1986 and also burr
Tosh was telling Marta about there was
an urban legend or like a ghost story
about a body that was at the bottom of
the lake like this woman that would like
grab your legs and stuff like that and
that was talking about her mom who had
been killed in 1986 by her own mom and
that's so so it's like that kind of
thing like that didn't even I mean it
was kind of important to the story but
it's like I just like that he didn't
even like have to say about that like
ghost story in the lake or anything like
that they were just referring to in this
world where Katarina was killed back in
1986 where she wasn't supposed to
because she was in 2019 then there was
like this ghost story it wasn't about
this body in the water but who she was
in the water that's where she ended up
dead so it's just like I just love like
little [ __ ] like that another thing I
wanted to say too because this is
another question that a lot of people
had about the end of this show was that
so basically to end the show like I said
the origin was time travel itself so
basically
yonas from vinden a and Marta from
venden B had to go essentially outside
of time so like during the apocalypse
that was like there was like a moment
where time stopped and causality was
suspended so they had to go outside of
that so that they could both enter the
origin world and prevent the accident
which killed tan house
family and made him want to build a time
machine in the first place
so and then after that when that
happened when they prevented the
accident then they knew that that was
that they would be sacrificing not only
themselves because you know these two
worlds would no longer exist but they
were also sacrificing everyone else in
the other two looped worlds that were
only born because of time travel so a
lot of people this exists it's funny
because Netflix did like a video about
like explaining everything and they did
the thing like at the end like they had
this gameshow voice and he's like here's
who doesn't exist anymore because all
these people got wiped out because a lot
of the people like an alarming number of
people were only alive in those two
looped worlds because someone had
time-traveled you know what I mean so
there were like whole family lines that
were like wiped out I mean they didn't
die they just never existed because
those two worlds were never supposed to
exist in the first place my
understanding of how it would work let's
say you went back and killed your own
mom to prevent your birth alright you
could go and do it after you killed your
mom you wouldn't vanish you'd still be
there you would remember everything but
nobody else would because evidently
the universe doesn't care about where
matter came from it only cares that it
exists now
so because you were existed in the time
as an adult when you killed your mom it
didn't matter that you weren't born yet
because you were there you traveled back
yeah yeah because you you you're already
it in the future existed in the future
once they went into a little bit and
this should be like erasing your own
tracks right you're still standing there
yeah you go back kill your mom you'd
erased your all your tracks no one would
remember your birth yeah but you'd still
be there in that time because you
because you had to be alive together
exactly and now if you went back to
where you came from and tried to read go
back in your own life that wouldn't be
there anymore no one would know you you
would have never been born and yes
that's how it would work but the thing
is is that they're pretty sure you can't
go into the past
it's easy to go
to the future yeah well that all doing
it satellites are going satellites are
traveling into the future all time the
clocks have to be adjusted if you go
fast enough you move forward in time
yeah going through space is the same as
going through time yeah faster you're
going through space the faster you're
going forward in time as you approach
the speed of light you're going into the
future time for you kind of slows down
relative there but it's einstein's
[ __ ] special relativity yeah but
there doesn't seem to be any way to go
backwards in time so yeah because look
at all of it like I said just look at
the complexity of this show and look at
the [ __ ] family trees of people like
because people would travel back in time
and you know father people that were
still you know what I mean is it and
they'd be still alive it's kind of like
what is that's like the grandfather
paradox just don't like that if you go
back in time and kill your granddad it's
as if the past no longer exists yeah
it's gone it's not it is not a reality
yeah the universe doesn't care what
happened in the past it's vanished yeah
you can't go there but the thing that
interested me and a lot of people have
pointed this out was that okay so I
really really love the way they ended
this and it was so this is the last
season they didn't want to do any more
than that because they wanted it all to
be in threes you know to me because like
I said they've kind of thought of
everything it's all themed and
everything so you know they ended it
really good it's like it's a bittersweet
ending because a lot of the characters
that you watched for like two and a half
seasons don't exist anymore because like
I said yonus doesn't exist MARTA doesn't
exist actually all of the Nielsen family
line doesn't exist because Ulrich never
existed so like Charlotte doesn't exist
like all these people don't exist
because they were only alive because of
time-travel like in the loop and
everything sander says she went back in
time when she was again yes the future
when she went to the Germany but the
thing about it is that some people have
been pointing out they're like because
this show is big on paradoxes and they
go a lot into like different types of
paradoxes one paradox that a lot of
people pointed out which I guess kind of
is a paradox
is that so if Jonas and Marta went
outside of time a you know so
like during that moment and prevented
the accident that kept tan house from
wanting to build you know it to invent
time travel to start with then you know
so him never inventing time travel
wouldn't that negate yonus and Marta
even being there to do that because they
were only there because time travel had
been invented you know what I'm saying
neither one of them would have existed
without time travel you know because
they were born of you know the two loop
worlds that bust it out when he made the
time machine and so without time travel
neither one of them would exist so the
fact that they were there to essentially
go outside of time go back to the origin
world and stop him from inventing time
travel is in itself a paradox you know
what I'm saying yeah so but you could
argue some people have argued that maybe
there is another version of the world
where they did not prevent the accident
or it's another thing to is that H maybe
HG tan house did invent the time machine
and all of this looping however long it
took and it took that long for
everything to loop through like infinite
times or how many times it did it for
yonus and Marta to get to that point so
they could prevent it from happening and
that you know maybe that so he ended up
actually saving his family without
realizing that he had saved his family
because in that origin world where they
prevented the accident from happening he
didn't ever invent time travel and
didn't know time travel existed but he
saved them anyway without knowing it
by in by essentially inventing a time
machine [ __ ] up two worlds getting
them blown up and then everything coming
back to kind of like reset itself like I
said this is it's a heavy [ __ ] ship
and it's like kind of a lot too that's
why I don't really recommend like watch
I watched it like like I would watch
like three or four episodes and I it and
you know I'd watch like two or three at
once but um you know it's it does kind
of like you really do have to like keep
track of everything but as I said I'd
preferred like watching it you know all
within a closed time period because you
appreciate it a lot more because you
pick up like a lot more of the little
details yeah and you know cuz there's
just [ __ ] so much going on of this and
I'm in a way like I'm from a writing
point of view I was like found this
really inspiring that the writers were
just that [ __ ] clip and and like I
said I could just imagine what their
[ __ ] notes looked like and they it
must have been like flowcharts and
[ __ ] all kind of [ __ ] like all over
the wall just to like figure out it's
like how did they keep all that [ __ ]
straight I just have no idea it's just
like and it was just an amazing feat and
I mean it was really one of the best
sci-fi movies one of the best
time-travel things that I've ever it's
just the amount of thought that went
into it is just mind-blowing to me and
you know the [ __ ] that it brought up you
know it's the whole thing it's it's a
very deep philosophical discussion about
how you know one person's grief had like
caused this endless loop of suffering
and all these people couldn't get out of
it and you know and just kind of the
tragedy of that and then interestingly
too I liked that they ended it like
after you know Eunice and Martha prevent
the accident and all of the people that
were only in the two looped vindens you
know because of time travel they all
disintegrated as they would and then you
see the origin world and you see of the
only the handful of characters that were
still actually alive in the origin world
that you know that existed outside of
time travel so they were still there and
you saw Hannah who was Eunice's mom in
the in the other worlds but obviously
it's not his mom in this one cuz he
doesn't exist because Mikkel doesn't
exist who was his dad and she's pregnant
with Peter VARs child and she says that
you know she talks about this dream she
had where she dreamed it was the
apocalypse her everything went black but
it was okay like it was good so it's
almost kind of like she dreamed that all
of these carrot other characters
suffering had come to an end which is
what they wanted they wanted out of the
loop and then she sees like the iconic
yellow raincoat and there
okay what are you gonna name the kid and
she said yonis is a beautiful name so
they're trying to kind of give hope that
now obviously this isn't going to be the
yonas because the dad is different even
though the mom is the same so we're left
to wonder you know I don't think there
could be any other version of yonus or
Marta or any of the other like
disintegrated characters like Magnus or
anybody like that in this other world
because a lot of the characters that
birthed them or you know a lot of the
situations that birthed them don't exist
like for example in the origin world if
I don't know if you guys noticed this
but in the origin world the nuclear
power plant never got built and because
the nuclear power plant only got built
because in the loop in the you know
infinite loop worlds because the unknown
went and threatened the dude to sign the
building permit because he wasn't going
to he wasn't going to give them a
building permit in the 50s so the
unknown went back and like threatened to
kill that guy unless he signed the
building permit so the nuclear power
plant could be built but since that
didn't happen in the origin world the
nuclear power plant was never built and
Regina never got cancer as a result she
focuses shifts to company she she's a
writer she's big into these big [ __ ]
works of art in terms of [ __ ] story
telling me I like my time-travel simple
my favorite time travel story was from
Star Trek Enterprise I think it was like
season 3 in a mirror darkly 1 & 2 where
Archer evil Archer in the mirror
universe buy some [ __ ] information
from a bunch of gangsters that the
tholians has somehow stolen a damn
Federation space ship the USS Defiant
its stole it from the future
yeah which tied in to the original
series when Kirk went to go find out
what was wrong with the Defiant it was
in Spanish like that I like that it's
slipping away into uh this this
time-space is unstable it's going away
and [ __ ] Kurt teleports
over there yeah yeah yeah that's a Kirk
out he's in that damn spacesuit like
this you know and he's in he's in
between dimensions like a ghost and [ __ ]
they thought he was dead and then the
Defiant vanishes and never in the
original series do you find out what the
hell happened to the Defiant well they
went backwards in time into a into the
[ __ ] mirror universe the evil Ryu
naver's [ __ ] 200 years before the
steth all Ian stole it and the Stallions
were these damn crystal and spiders that
were so [ __ ] alien and strange that
they could figure out how to [ __ ] with
space and time because even the Vulcans
said no time travel is not possible and
you know it went into the past but you
see that was a different theoretically
maybe something like that's real yeah
because the Defiant didn't go into the
past
under the diff'ent from the defiance
point of view mahom was is that Thal
Ian's in the present opened the door to
the future and the future is more real
than the past and brought it through
okay so only from the point of view of
the Defiant did it go into this yeah I
gotcha from the point of view of the
Thal hints they went into the future and
got it see and something like that might
actually be a reality in physics yeah
okay cuz everything has to be relative
maybe you can't go into the past but
maybe somebody from maybe if somebody
from the present can pull somebody from
the future into now was from our point
of view would be a bridge to the future
stealing something from the few right
and from their point of view there boy
they'd be going in fast but they
couldn't be in in the future go I'm
gonna jump into the past yeah you can't
in other words you have to have somebody
in the past pulling you and Dad does
they have to bring you there you have to
bring you there yeah there'd be some
weird [ __ ] see anytime you get anything
to do with time travel in physics and
relative relativity and physics it's all
weird like I said we don't know how much
of this is possible because like I said
even though on the surface some of the
[ __ ] that happens in dark like for
example you know the first main thing
that happens Mikkel
through the wormhole going back to 1986
and you know fathering
yonis later on even though him and Jonas
existed in the same you know time period
like but obviously like mikkel wasn't
there anymore he went missing but nobody
knew where he went until they figured
out he went back asking me am I'm just
here to look pretty yeah but yeah so I
mean if you could like and like I said
the whole [ __ ] with um with Charlotte
like going but and people like meeting
not even just meeting but like hanging
out with you know the older and younger
versions of themselves like people like
constantly going back in time to tell
their younger self like virtually hey I
know some [ __ ] from the future and like
you have to know this that the other
like it was just on this constant
recursive loop where you know people
kept going back in time to tell their
younger selves [ __ ] and then like so you
know then as it got more complicated
like [ __ ] was splitting off at at two
different realities like I said because
you know and then there was that whole
switch point at the end where Marta got
shot and then either other either alt
martha came and like saved yonus or she
didn't go she went with bartosh and went
back to 1888 or whatever it were 18 92
or whatever it was when stranger yonus
was back there like trying to build the
Tesla coil I tried to build a time
machine back then with all that [ __ ]
technology and not doing too well so
it's just like that was another thing
too is that you also really have to keep
track of which because in this universe
people who go back in time you can still
I mean you can be there with an older
version of yourself so you have to keep
track and there and so and because at
one point there was like a split you
have to keep track of like which version
of who is doing what and like knows what
because if this person is like a week
ahead of that person even though they
look the same you know this person has
knowledge that this one doesn't have
because this one is like from a week in
the future yeah and a pet that was the
only bit that like confused me a little
bit at the end because I lost track of
which Marta was
which like which one saved yonus and
brought her brought him to the other
world and it's like then which yonis
wasn't the gunshot but like after i
watched it like kind of through again
and I was just like okay I got it now
but you really have to keep track they
usually do a good job of you know trying
to keep you apprised of that either by
the clothes they're wearing or like a
particular scar like it what like marta
has like a cut on her little cheek but
then she has a cut on her eye as well
and that shows she's like from a little
bit later so you kind of keep track of
who's who and like who knows what um I
did forget that when one of the Marta's
went back to 1888 that stranger yonus
there didn't know who she was exactly
like he knew about his Marta but they
were the two universes were slightly
different so she was still Marta but she
wasn't the exact same Marta's you
notices original world so the fact that
he didn't know that was like confusing
for a second but then I was like okay I
got it now but um yeah this is like this
is one of those shows and it's like
there's a whole fuss overload in me I
can't know I didn't I couldn't really I
didn't really watch it yeah I only
watched a few episodes and I was just so
[ __ ] lost it did look cool but it's
it is like I said you have to watch
every single [ __ ] app you really
really have to attention to it and
that's really I could do that I could do
that with certain subject matters but
not with something like fiction like
this yeah I just don't care enough yeah
but I mean I don't know I just think
they did a really good job like of you
know getting you emotionally invested in
the characters getting like and and it
just being this you know it's cool that
it's like a big puzzle to figure out but
you also did like give a [ __ ] about the
kids like I was super bummed out when I
realized at the end you know when just
you know those few people were sitting
around the dinner table and I was just
like oh yeah nobody else exists because
they were all products of time travel
like of various kinds like somebody had
to go back in time to father them or
whatever the case was so I was like so
all these people didn't exist anymore
which I guess what like I said it made
me sad but then in another way that's
kind of what they wanted because like I
said they you know their suffering was
endless and they kept
doing the same thing over and over I
don't think a lot of the characters were
aware of that but some of them were how
many seasons are there three it's three
seasons oh thank you very much Megan
thank you mango mango Badger flash mob
yeah the future was somehow access in
the past so there's three seasons is
over or they make it it's over that's
all yeah this it's completed and
honestly I think they did it I mean that
it was perfect I love the way they ended
it I love that it's completely
self-contained I love that the first
like I said the first season was almost
kind of like a police procedural or like
a crime drama but with some sci-fi
elements then the second one like
expanded it out even more time travel
and then the third one just went whole
hog with like alternate realities time
traveled time loops and all this other
kind of stuff so it like kept building
onto the world and like getting bigger
and bigger and more vast in scope and I
just thought that was really really cool
the way they pulled it off and I really
really liked the way they ended it
because it was like sad but also kind of
like hopeful you know what I mean so I
thought that was kind of like the
perfect ending I just and it seems like
most people really really liked the
ending because you know how some people
get with series and they're just kind of
like oh well I wish it would have ended
like this or but that's on Netflix okay
and like I said it's if you haven't seen
it it's German it's weird because it was
first recommended to me by a friend of
mine and this was one season one just
came out and basically they were like
hey you like stranger things you
probably like this too and I guess on
the surface it is a little bit like
stranger things just in this fact that
it's sci-fi and then there's like part
of it that's set in the 80s but other
than I mean this is like a zillion times
more complex and adults themed the
stranger things I love stranger things
but that is definitely more it's not kid
oriented necessarily but I mean it is
more kid centric I guess and it's a lot
simpler storyline to follow this one is
like much more adult much more layered
this one is just like a big huge
intricate novel you know what I mean
with just like zillions of like
overlapping timelines and characters and
everything
and you really have to give but I think
it really does if you like that kind of
thing
it really does reward you know attention
to it and it's kind of one of those
things that people are gonna get
obsessive about I mean there's already a
whole reddit threads about people
talking about this and that and the in
the theoretical physics of hey what
about this and what about that and what
about that guy and all this other kind
of stuff so um oh I also want to give a
shout out to the Peter of aller what
happened to his I joke okay so you never
do find out what happened to the dudes I
because this is one thing that I was
wondering people going on it no I've got
no I told you I'm gonna spoil it yeah
you know I told you right
see after see everybody wondered that
because in the first season he had
clearly like messed up his eye because
he had like a bandage around it the
whole time but they never really
mentioned like they never really mention
it you know they didn't no one brought
attention to it
then in the second season he had like
this eyepatch with like a dark glass
over and everything and there was a one
of the characters I think it was Klaus
in like asked him what happened to his
eye and vollar says he's like you
promise you won't tell anybody and he's
like yeah I won't tell anybody
and he's like oh well last summer and
then like you know Klaudia runs in front
of their car and they said so he never
finds out so then at the very very end
of the show the end of season 3 after
the after the looping worlds have been
destroyed and Peter volar is sitting
there with his wife Hannah who is his
wife in the origin world and they asked
they said oh your eye looks better
because now he doesn't have like the the
thing on but he just has a scratch on
there and they said and they're like you
never did tell us how you how you did
that and he's like oh well you know last
summer boa and then the back say you
never find out what happened to his eye
now what I read I don't know if this is
true or not but I read that the actor
that they cast to be in it shortly
before filming started he [ __ ] his eye
all up and had to wear a thing and they
didn't want to replace him so they said
well we'll just write it into the show
but because they didn't they just
thought it would be funnier to like make
it a running joke where he would go to
tell somebody what happened to his eye
and it was really embarrassing but then
something would always happen to prevent
him telling you why like telling you
what happened to it so that's what I
heard I don't know if that's true or not
some people do have theories about what
happened to his how I liked that
Gretchen the dog did it it's like I've
seen all kinds of different theories but
it's just like kind of fun to think of
but I think they just put it in there as
like a running joke another thing I kind
of wondered about too and this is a
little probably the last thing I'll
bring up but I did kind of wonder if
there was any significance to Alexander
T Turman because he comes to vinden
later
so he's like from the outside and yet
you know there was a whole thing they
don't they just imply it but they don't
really say he supposedly killed a dude
in Marburg either accidentally on
purpose
he says accidentally but I'm not really
sure and then what happened he actually
killed somebody and took their identity
and then came to vinden and then you
know ended up taking over the nuclear
power plant but I don't know if if him
like the crime that he committed outside
of the town if that has relevance or if
it's only relevant because he ended up
coming to the town and him getting
arrested for the identity theft was what
caused Clausen to get the search warrant
for the nuclear power plant which is
what caused the dark matter to bust out
of the the canisters and like cause the
start of the apocalypse so I think that
he was just like the catalyst for that
but he had to come from outside of the
town
I guess because he was one of the only
him and Peter Doppler I guess he was
from outside of the town too but um so I
don't know if there was any significance
to like the murder that he committed or
you know the accidental homicide that he
committed like outside of the town other
than that's what brought him there
because he was running away so you know
that was another thing that I would have
liked a little bit more about but I
don't know if it was necessarily
relevant it was just something that got
him there and and it had to be something
illegal because they had to get a search
warrant because they thought that he was
a murderer so yeah alright so anyway
what you guys like Tammy says I know I
was dying to find out what happened to
his eye I know everybody was it's I
think they did put stuff in here that
they just thought would be funny and
like they that people would like
theorize about
but pretty much mostly everything has
like a meeting though all right so I
guess that'll do it for our yeah going
on for a wrap-up yeah well is it it
didn't seem like it cuz like I said I
got really really into this show Anna
flake and I was like I wanted somebody
else to talk to about it because it's
like so complicated and I was just like
and I was just and I was just so in awe
of like the writing and how everything
fit together and it just like kind of
blew my mind I probably will watch the
whole thing through at some other point
in the near future but anyway thank you
guys for coming by we will probably do
another livestream excuse me we're
probably do another livestream tomorrow
it's tomorrow Tuesday yeah we'll
probably do a sidetracks or maybe we'll
do a movie review if we watch something
new tonight we'll see how it goes
but until then we will talk to you guys
next time bye